my name is sandeep mukha padhai and i am
the program director
i am an associate professor in marketing
at imt ghaziabad let me welcome you to
the digital marketing program offered by
one of the most prestigious business
schools imt gajiabad in collaboration
with simply learn
join one of today's fastest growing
fields
introducing a professional certificate
in digital marketing program
with this program you will become a
digital marketing expert leveraging live
online classes by imt faculty and
industry experts
you will master in demand skills such as
social media
seo and ppc
and tools such as semrush
google ads
meta ads and youtube analytics and you
will also join the world's leading
digital marketing experts in level up
sessions
meet your trainers and program advisors
professor sandeep mukhopadhyay associate
professor at imt
mba from iim kolkata professor bindu
gupta professor of ob and hrm at imt 20
years of experience
professor shubha lakshmi best bharava
learn with 25 plus hands-on projects and
showcase your skills to employers with a
capstone in five domains and get an
opportunity to attend master sessions
and amas by meta blueprint trainers with
this program you will be on your way to
landing your dream marketing role with a
professional certificate from imt
gaziabad and simply learns job assist
program and an exclusive perk join the
coveted imt ghaziabad associate alumni
association
you will join a global community of top
notch dm professional and walk into that
next interview brimming with confidence
so start building your digital marketing
career with a professional certificate
in digital marketing from imt gaziabad
and simply learn
apply now
i